نتابع هذا الخبر الذي اعلنته منظمه الصحه
العالميه لنزوح اكثر من 43 الف شخص من
درنه الى مناطق ليبيه اخرى وذلك بسبب
عاصفه دانيال المدمره ومن جهه اعلنت
السلطات تقسيمه مدينه درنه وفق الاضرار
التي نجمت عن العاصفه لتسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ وفي ظروف صعبه للغايه تستمر عمليه
انتشار الجثث ورفع الانقاض في المناطق
المنكوبه وسط تضاءل الامال للعثور على
ناجي
فاجعه درن التي تكبر مع كل رقم جديد
للقتله والمنكوبين والمفقودين بلغت
الماساه درجه اصبحت فيها اقصى الامنيات
العثور على جثه قريب لاكرامه بالدفن يا رب
رحمتك بينا يا رب
رحمتك بينا يا رب دفن البعض خلال الايام
الاولى للماساه في مقابر جماعيه دون تحديد
هويتهم ويعقد مهمه البعض لمعرفه مصير
ذويهم ابتلع البحر الكثير منهم وتحاول فرق
الانقاذ في ظروف صعبه انتشال الجثث عائلات
باكملها لم يعد لها وجود ولا لما كانت
يوما بيوتهم اعلنت السلطات الليبيه تقسيم
المدينه وفق الاضرار التي لحقت باحيائها
تنص الخطه على اخلاء الاحياء الاكثر تضررا
من سكانها لتسهيل عمل فرق الانقاذ وحمايه
الناجين من انتشار الامراض تستعد منظمه
الصحه العالميه لاي طارئ وتواصل فرقها
جهودها لتوفير المستلزمات الطبيه
والمساعدات للمناطق النائيه في محيط
الدرنه مع معالي الوزير اتفقنا اليوم انه
يكون في تقريبا
شراكه بين المنظمه وفرق الوزاره هنا في
شرق ليبيا لكي نحاول الرفع من وصول
الاهالي لكل الخدمات الصحيه منها الرعايه
الصحيه الاوليه وكذلك بعد الخدمات من
الرعايه الثانيه او المتخصصه
عشره الاف النازحين يواجهون مصيرا مجهولا
في بلد غارق في الفوضى منذ 2011 اكثر من
ثلاثه واربعين الف نازح هو الرقم الذي
اعلنته في الساعات الاخيره المنظمه
الدوليه للهجره تتحدث المنظمه عن نزوحي
نحو
24,500 شخص من مدينه درنه وحدها بسبب نقص
امدادات المياه الذي اعقد السيول المدمره
وفي البيضاء نزع نحو ثلاثه الاف شخص من
منازلهم بسبب فيضانات في مدينه بنغازي
اجبر اكثر من
2780 شخصا على التركي عليهم كما اجبر نحو
الفي شخص في مدينه الابرق ونحو 1500 شخص
في كل من المرج وتكرا على مغادره الديار
قصرا على وجوه الناجين صدمه الفقدان وعلى
السنتهم اسماء من غيبوا في كابوس عاصفه
دمرت سدين اغرق درنا في كارثه غير مسبوقه
يطول الانتظار المر لمعرفه مصير الاقارب
والجيران حداد ليبيا لن ينتهي قريبا ودرنا
لتعود كما كانت قبل ما فعله بها دانيال
وعواصف اخرى
من جانب وزير الصحه الليبيه في الحكومه
المكلفه من البرلمان عثمان عبد الجليل ان
الوضع الصحي في درنه مستقر وسط جهود
عالميه للتخفيف من وطاه الكارثه واكد عبد
الجليل الحرصه على استخدام الطرق العلميه
السليمه بالتعامل مع الكارثه
الوضع الصحي بدا يتعافى يعني هناك
مستشفيات ميدانيه موجوده كل الخدمات
الصحيه يتم تقديمها للمواطنين اعتقد لو
فيه قصور يكون
جزئي او في بعض الاشياء يعني وهذه نسحوا
لتوفيرها لكن معظم الخدمات الاساسيه
موجوده والحمد لله يعني وما زلنا في تطوير
للموضوع هذا
[موسيقى]
الان الى المغرب حيث تتواصلوا عمليات
اغاثه المنكوبين بعد نحو اسبوعين من زلزال
الحوس في الاثناء تواصل السلطات الجهود
لتنفيذ البرنامج العاجل لايواء المتضررين
واعاده الاعمار وقالت وزاره الصحه ان عدد
الجرح الذين تكفلت بهم وزاره الصحه بلغت
1676 شخصا
كما اكد المتحدث باسم الحكومه المغربيه
مصطفى بانياس ان فاجعه الزلزال تطلب
التدخل الدوله بمختلف مؤسساتها ومصالحها
من اجل مساعده المتضررين واضاف ان المرحله
القادمه تقتضي البناء واعاده الحياه الى
المناطق المتضرره بسرعه
وفعاليه ونجاعه
المرحله الاولى اللي كانت فيها صعوبات
اللي كان فيها الم اللي كان فيها يعني
واحد النوع ديال الحزن الحمد لله الجميع
تعبئ الان مشينا المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله
البناء هي مرحله كيفاش نعيد الحياه لهذه
المناطق كلها المتضرره بسرعه ولكن ماشي
فقط السرعه ولكن ايضا بفعاليه وبنجاعه
وباش هاد المناطق هادي تكون عندها واحد
القدره على انها تملك مقومات اقتصاديه
حقيقيه من اجل ان تساهم واحد المساهمه
كبيره في النتيجه الداخلي الخام وهاد
الناس هادو يعيشوا في كرامه
وكان زلزال الحوز الذي ضرب المغرب غير
حياه الناجين واجبرهم على اتباع اساليب
جديده يشكو السكان من غياب الخدمات
الاساسيه وسط مخاوف من قدوم فصل الشتاء
قبل ان يتوفر لديهم ما يحتاجونه من مؤونه
وتدفئه مراسلنا عن عمر الحاج زارا بلده
ثلاث يعقوب في اقليم الحوز واعد هذا
التقرير
تعود عفاف للتوي الى خيمتها بعد ان قطعت
كيلومترات عده لتشحن هاتفها
هي واحده من منكوبي بلده ثلاث يعقوب فقدت
منزلها وسته افراد من العائله
علمتها الكارثه استخدام المتوفر بحذر
واجبرتها على استخدام موارد جديده لم تعهد
كالواحد طاقه الشمسيه
تمكنت مع عائلتها من استخراج بعض اسطوانات
الغاز السليمه لكن ذلك لم يمنعهم من جمع
الحطب والاستعداد لما هو اسوء
اللي مات وولده هو اللي مات والناس راه
تكرفصو في هاد الزلزال الناس ما كاينش
دابا يعني كاين البرد هنا بالزاف في هذا
الشتوى ما كاينش شي حاجه يعني الكيا يعني
غير ثوب يعني الناس مكرفصه بزاف وكنتمنى
من سيدي ربي تعاون تعاونوا الناس هنايا
بنادم مكرفص
والماء ما كاينش
غير الزلزال حياه سكان البلده
وغير بشكل كامل ملامحها وعادات اهلها
الذين سيتفرقون مختارين بعد ان تقرر نقل
المرضى والطلبه الى المدينه
نتيجه الدمار الذي لحق بالمؤسسات جهود
الاغاثه الحكوميه والاهليه مستمره كمؤسسه
رفقه الخير اللي احنا في الاصل كان نقوم
بانشطه قبل الزلزال
بعد تاسيس هذا المؤسسه هو الاساس
بالتاسيسها ومساعده
اناس يقطنون بالجبال بالجبال الحوز بمناطق
الجبليه بالمغرب بصفه عامه هذا هو
الامتياز الذي اللي خلانا اننا نتوفق ولله
الحمد باننا نوصلوا
نوصلوا للحاجيات والخصائص الفعلي من خلال
الافتحاص القبلي
ما تزال الطريق الموصله الى القريه تعاني
انهيارات صخريه ولم تسترد بعد الخدمات
الاساسيه
ورغم محاولات اقناع الناجين بالاجلاء الى
مكان اكثر امنا فان اغلبهم متمسكون
بالبقاء
عيش جديده فرضها الزلزال على المتضررين
ستغير بلا شك شكل الحياه التي اعتادوا
عليها لا خيار لهم الان الا التكيف مع هذه
الانماط فعمليه التعافي من اثار الزلزال
ستاخذ وقتا ليس بالقصير عمر الحاجه
الجزيره من بلده تلات يعقوب مراكش
[موسيقى]
قلى مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي جيكس ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن سيعلن اليوم عن
مساعدات جديده لاوكرانيات تتضمن قدرات
دفاع جوي كبير واضاف السالفن خلال مؤتمر
صحفي في البيت الابيض هل هذه المساعدات
الجديده ستعزز دفاعات اوكرانيا قبل حلول
فصل الشتاء
سيعلن رئيس بايدن اليوم عن حزمه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه تتضمن قدرات دفاع جوي
كبيره لمساعده اوكرانيا على حمايه شعبها
هذه القدرات ستساعد اوكرانيا على تعزيز
دفاعاتها قبل الشتاء يرجح ان يكون قاسيا
بهجمات روسيه متجدده على البنيه التحتيه
الحيويه الاوكرانيه ستحرم ابرياء من
مستلزمات كالتدفئه والكهرباء وبما ان
الرئيس بوتين غير قادر على تحقيق اهدافه
في ساحه المعركه فانه يلجا الى هجمات تهدف
الى اغراق السكان العاديين في البرد
والظلام ونعمل مع الاوكرانيين لتعقيد تلك
المهمه على روسيا
كما حذر الرئيس الاوكراني
النواب الجمهوريين في الكونغرس من
الحيلوله دون اقرار حزمه جديده من
المساعدات الامريكيه لاوكرانيا وقال
تواجه خطر خساره الحرب امام روسيا في حال
توقف تدفق الدعم ياتي هذا في وقت يطالب
فيه الجمهوريون برقابه على الاموال
الامريكيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا
نحو 600 يوم من الحرب زمن كاف للقول ان
روسيا اخفقت في ادراك نصر حاسم كانت تتطلع
اليه وزمن كاف ايضا للتساؤل ان كان ثمه
تململ داخل المعسكر الحليفه من طول امد
الحرب يصل الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي
ميرزيلانسكي الى واشنطن طلبا لتعهد من
رئيس بايدن بان يبقي على زخم دعمه العسكري
لكييف لكن زياره زيلينسكي هذه المره وهي
الثانيه له منذ الحرب تختلف عن سابقتها اذ
بات الخصوم الجمهوريون لبايدن يمسكون
بالغالبيه في مجلس النواب وعليه فان
الرئيس الاوكراني لن يحظى هذه المره
باستقبال احتفاليه في مبنى الكابيتول كما
جرى في عهد الديمقراطيين
افتتصاعد اصوات داخل الكونجرس يقودها
الجمهوريون لفرض رقابه على الاموال
المغلقه على اوكرانيا يقول زعيم الغالبيه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب كيفن وكارتي ان
لديه اسئله يريد طرحها على زيلينسكي بشان
مصير الاموال الامريكيه والسبيل لتحقيق
الانتصار تقود الولايات المتحده تحالف
رامشتاين الذي يضم 50 دوله بمثاق ينص على
الدعم العسكري لا محدود لاوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا منذ الرابع والعشرين من
يناير 2022 وحتى يونيو الماضي تتجاوز
التقديرات بالدعم الغربي لكييف 166 مليار
دولار
48% من هذا الدعم كان لاغراض عسكريه على
علاقه بميدان الحرب اما الباقي فكان دعما
ماليا لحكومه زيلانسكي ومساعدات انسانيه
80 مليار دولار هي قيمه الدعم العسكري
الغربي من الخوذ والدروع الواقيه من
الرصاص الى انظمه الدفاع الصاروخي
والدبابات وتجري الاستعدادات لتزويد كييف
بمقاتلات اف 16
تصدرت اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الداعمين اذ
قدمت الولايات المتحده وحدها 71 مليار
دولار يليها الاتحاد الاوروبي بخمسه
وثلاثين مليار دولار تاتي بريطانيا ثالثا
اذ قارب ما قدمته لاوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب
11 مليار دولار اما المانيا التي عرضت في
البدايه المساهمه باسلحه ثقيله لكنها
استسلمت في النهايه لضغط من حلفائها فقارب
دعمها 11 مليار دولار من بينها نحو 8
مليارات لاغراض عسكريه منذ بدء الحرب قادت
بولندا الجار الاوروبي الاقرب لاوكرانيا
ما وصف بمعسكر الصقور الداعم لكييف لكنها
اليوم تتراجع على نحو لافت خطوه الى
الوراء يقول رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتوشمورفيتسكي ان بولندا توقفت عن تسليح
اوكرانيا وانها تركز فقط على تعزيز قوتها
الدفاعيه والواضح ان رئيس الوزراء
البولندي بموقفه هذا انما يوازن ما بين
استحقاقات انتخابات تستعد لها البلاد
الشهر المقبل وبين تعهدات بولندا العضو في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو واكثر المتخوفين
من ان تتجاوز طموحات روسيا اوكرانيا الى
جيرانها
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه اذا لم يتم
الوقوف مع اوكرانيا فلن تكون هناك اي دوله
في العالم في مامن وخلال لقائه نظيره
الاوكراني في البيت الابيض اضاف بايدن ان
شجاعه الاوكرانيين في الدفاع عن حريتهم
ومبادئهم الهمت العالم حسب تعبيره وفي
المقابل عبر زيلينسكي عن تقديره للمساعده
التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده لبلاده في
مكافحه الارهاب الروسي بحسب تعبيره مشيرا
الى انه اجرى حوارا وصفه بالصريح مع اعضاء
الكونجرس وانه سيركز في نقاشاته مع بايدن
على الحاجه الاوكرانيه لاسلحه الدفاع
الجوي
تنضم الان الينا من البيت الابيض مراسلتنا
وجد وقفي اهلا وجد اذا هذه المره الثانيه
التي يلتقي فيها بايدن وزلنسكي في البيت
الابيض كيف تختلف هذه الزياره عن سابقتها
من حيث السياق ومن حيث التوقعات كذلك
مرحبا ليلى طبعا هذه الزياره تاتي في خضام
الهجوم المضاد الذي الذي بداته اوكرانيا
لذلك فان البيت الابيض يعتبر ان توقيت هذه
الزياره توقيت حساس جدا نظرا
لاستمرار الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد والحاجه
الملحه للاسلحه التي تحتاجها اوكرانيا
وايضا نظرا لما قال
بانه استمرار روسيا في هجومها على شبكه
البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه لابقاء الشعب
الاوكراني المدنيين في ظلام دامس اكد بان
الاداره الامريكيه تعمل مع اوكرانيا من
اجل التخفيف من وطاه هذه الهجمات حقيقه
التوقيت له علاقه ايضا ليلى بحزمه
المساعدات التي طلبتها او تحتاجها
اوكرانيا وطلبتها الاداره الامريكيه من
الكونجرس بدايه 24 مليار دولار
الرئيس بايدن من الكونغرس لتغطيه تكلفه
الحرب او المساعدات الامنيه الامريكيه
خلال هذه الحرب للعام المقبل هناك كما
ذكرتم اصوات من الجمهوريين المعارضين
والذين يطرحون الكثير من التساؤلات عن
اولا الى متى
ستستمر الاداره الولايات المتحده في
ارسال كل هذه الاسلحه الى متى سوف تنتهي
هذه الحرب وما الى ذلك لذلك الرئيس
الاوكراني زيلنسكي جلس اليوم مع قاده
الكونغرس من الحزبين الجمهوري والديمقراطي
من المجلسين النواب والشيوخ وشرح لهم
احتياجات اوكرانيا وضروره استمرار تدفق
هذه المساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا اوكرانيا
تحتاج ايضا الى امر لن تزوده بها الاداره
تزودها بها الاداره الامريكيه في الوقت
الحالي وهي صواريخ تكتيكيه بعيده المدى او
الاتاكانز بحسب التسميه الامريكيه
يحتاج هذه الصواريخ لكن جيك سالفا مستشار
رئيس الامريكي للامن القومي قال انه لن
يتم ارسال هذه الصواريخ ضمن الحزمه
الامنيه التي سوف يعلن علي عليها الرئيس
بايدن بعد دقائق من الان ولكنه قال هذه
الصواريخ التكتيكيه سوف تبقى على طاوله
الخيارات المستقبليه اذا من المقرر ليلى
ان نسمع خلال دقائق قليله من الرئيس
الامريكي خلال الاجتماع الموسع الذي
يعقدهم مع انتظار ان نسمع ذلك شكرا جزيلا
لك وجد امام البيت الابيض
لذلك في تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
قال الجيش الاوكراني نادي دفاعاته تصدت
لسته 36 صاروخ الروسيا من اصل 43
عشرون منها في هجوم على العاصمه على
العاصمه عفوا مما اسفر عن اصابه سبعه
مدنيين وتضرر عدد من المباني والمنشات
وتتزايد المخاوف الاوكرانيه من ارتفاع
الهجمات الروسيه على منشات الطاقه خصوصا
مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
يزداد ذوي القصف في اوكرانيا بشكل غير
مسبوق فالحرب هناك تدخل مرحله جديده من
التصعيد والامر حسب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
نفسها اصبح مرعبا سماء اوكرانيا شهدت 43
صاروخا روسيا في هجمات متواصله تقول قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه متحدثه عن اسقاط 36
منها
العاصمه كييف وحدها استهدفت ب 20 صاروخا
ما اسفر عن اصابه عده اشخاص
مختلفه القصف طال مقاطعه شركاء جنوبي كييف
ايضا وفي غربي اوكرانيا تعرضت مقاطعه
ريفني لهجوم مشابه اصاب منشاه للطاقه ما
ادى الى انقطاع التيار الكهربائي عن نحو
400 مدينه وقريه بينها مناطق في مقاطعتكيف
اما في الفيف غربان فقد سقط صاروخان على
منطقه ما ادى الى تدمير منشاه صناعيه
ومخزن
الهجوم الروسي الكثيف خصوصا على منشات
الطاقه يجعل الصوره اكثر تهديدا اذ حذرت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه من اشهر وصفتها
بالصعبه في اعقاب الهجوم فمع قرب حلول فصل
الشتاء تخشى السلطات في كييف تكرار روسيا
استراتيجيه اعتمدتها عام 2022 وقامت
بالاساس على استهداف منشات الطاقه من اجل
قطع الكهرباء والتدفئه عن السكان وللمره
الاولى منذ سته اشهر تضررت منشات للطاقه
في غرب اوكرانيا ووسطها ورغم اعتراض
القوات الاوكرانيه غالبيه الصواريخ حسب
اعلانها الا ان عددا منها حقق اصابات
مباشره على الارض في مقابل الهجمات
الروسيه اعلن جهاز الامن المركزي
الاوكراني توجيه ضربه للقوات الروسيه في
مطار ساكي العسكري في شبه جزيره القرم وهو
احدث هجوم على المنطقه الواقعه على البحر
الاسود والتي تعهدت كييف باستعادتها في
مقابل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار اف شالها لما تعهدت به اوكرانيا
عبر تدمير 19 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
شبه جزيره القرن واكدت ان قواتها اسقطت
ايضا ثلاثه طائرات مسيره فوق مقاطعات
كورسيك وبيلوغرود
كبير الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسات كلوبساك
للدراسات اهلا وسهلا بك
اذا جيك سلفن يقول ان المساعدات الجديده
التي تقدمها واشنطن لكلاب ستمكنها من
تعزيز دفاعاتها قبل فصل الشتاء هل برايك
ستنجح بذلك فعلا
مساء من الصعب جدا ان نجيب على ذلك
فاوكرانيون كانوا يتوقعون في بدايه السنه
انه على ارجاع ينفد ما لديها من صواريخ
مضاده للطائرات تقريبا في هذا الوقت ومنذ
ذلك الحين حصلوا على الكثير منها ايضا
ولكن السؤال هو
هل ان كل تجزاتهم ستنتهي قبل ان تنتهي
خزين الصواريخ الروسيه سنعرف الجواب بعد
بعد
فصل الشتاء كما تعلمون تعرضت كيف الى سبعه
صواريخ وحصلن قطاعات للطاقه الكهربائيه
وبالتالي الحمله الجويه الشتويه قد بدات
وستكون معركه القادمه معركه دفاعات جويه
خطوره فعلا ان تعود موسكو الاستراتيجيتها
في عام 2022
باستهداف منشات الطاقه الى اي درجه فعلا
يشكل ربما نقطه
تغير المعادله
هذا سؤال مهم للغايه
فهذا هو ما يسمى
بالحمله الجويه الاستراتيجيه والهدف
الرئيسي منها طبعا هو المنظومات الطاقه
الكهربائيه
والتجهيزات المختلفه اللي تقدمها البلديات
ولكن هناك ايضا فكره هو التاثير على
معنويات الشعب الاوكراني فربما ينجح في
قطع القوه الكهربائيه واستهداف محطات
الطاقه وما الى ذلك من مشاه مهمه ولكن من
غير المحتمل ان ذلك سيؤثر او
يفكك
عزيمه واراده الشعب الاوكراني للقتال ولكن
ثم هناك هدف
انهاء كل ما لدى اوكرانيا من ذخائر للدفاع
الجوي طبعا لذلك الاولويه كما هو الحصول
على مثل هذه الذخائر نعم فصل الشتاء قادم
ويعني ربما مخاوف كثيره على بالنسبه
للطرفين برايك الى اي حد سيؤثر على مسار
المعركه هل سندخل في مرحله اللا غالب
والمغلوب ستيل ميت ام هناك ربما تغيير في
دفه الحرب
فيها ملايين
الامكانياته والحالات الطارئه وبالتالي
صعب التوقع حاليا على الارجح هناك ما يمكن
نقول قد تحصل حاله ركود
لتقفون عند بضعه كلمات هناك وهذا بالنسبه
يعني ان الحب ستكون طويله جدا الا اذا
حصلت اي اتفاق وقت اطلاق النار ولا اي
وليس نقل من يطلع لذلك حاليا وبالتالي هذه
حفص تكون طويله والنحو العسكريه
مرحله ركود او عدم حركه
اشكرك كفران كان من
مؤسسات كلوبساك للدراسات شكرا جزيلا لك
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه طارئه ومفتوحه
بشان التطورات في اقليم كاراباخ وقال
الامين العام المساعد لاوروبا واسيا
الوسطى
والامريكيتين ميروسلاف جينكا في احاطته
قال ان الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو يشعر بقلق بالغ ازاء استئناف
الاعمال العدائيه مؤخرا والذي ادى الى
خسائر ماساويه في ارواح البدنيين ودعا
جينكا الى وقف وقف موثوق ودائم لجميع
الاعمال العدائيه مؤكدا انا من شان اي
تصعيد متجدد ان يؤدي الى المزيد من
الخسائر في الارواح والمعاناه الانسانيه
والى المزيد من انتكاسات جهود السلام
المدعومه دوليا ومن جانبها قالت المندوبه
الامريكيه في مجلس الامن الدولي لندى
ان اذربيجان تتحمل مسؤوليه ضمان امتثال
قواتها بشكل صارم للقانون الدولي
وكانت الجوله الاولى من المحادثات بين
طرفي الصراع قد انتهت وكانت انعقدت في
يفلاغ في اب دربيجان برعايه الروسيه وقد
وصفت الرئاسه الاذربيجانيه الاجتماع
بالبناء وقالت انه تمت مناقشه قضايا اعاده
ادماج السكان الارمن في الاقليم خلال هذا
الاجتماع وتنظيم العمل كذلك وفقا لدستور
وقوانين جمهوريه اذربيجان ومن جهه قال
مستشار زعيم ارمن اقليمي كاراباخ الى
العمل ما زال جاريا على تفاصيل الاتفاق
ومنها تلك المتعلقه بتسليم السلاح اما في
ارمينيا فقد اتهم رئيس الوزراء نيكول
فاشينيان روسيا بالاخفاق في مهمه حفظ
السلام في اقليم
اجواء ايجابيه هكذا وصف بيان الرئاسه
الاذربيجانيه الجوله الاولى من المحادثات
مع ارمن اقليم كرباخ طرحت وفق البيان في
محادثات مدينه يفلاخ غرب العاصمه باكو
ملفات اعاده دمج ارمن كاراباخ وترميم بنيه
الاقليم التحتيه وتنظيم العمل وفق الدستور
والقوانين في اذربيجان علقت اذا ما وصفت
قبل يومين بعمليه مكافحه الارهاب التي
بداها وانهاها الجيش الاذربيجاني وهي سرعه
قياسيه بالنظر لتاريخ جولات الصراع حول
الاقليم بين اذربيجان وارمينيا تباها بها
يوم الاربعاء الرئيس الهام علياف معلنا
تحقيق كل اهداف العمليه لكن ارمن كاراباخ
الطرف الثاني في العمليه قالوا ان العمل
ما زال جاريا على تفاصيل الاتفاق وخاصه
مساله تسليم السلاح التي قال مستشار
زعيمهم ديفيد بابا يان انها ما بحاجه لحل
وان الضمانات الامنيه التي سيحصل عليها
الارمن غير معروفه مؤكدا على عدم رغبه
مواطنيه في العيش كجزء من اذربيجان ذاك
حلم كان الارمن يرقبونه من قديم ولكن بدعم
اقليمي وتحديدا من موسكو اليوم يرون ان
الجميع خذلهم بمن فيهم روسيا بل وحتى
ارمينيا نفسها فضلا عن الغرب ارمينيا
الحاضنه العرقيه الاقرب لارمن كاراباخ
تلام داخليا على نطاق واسع على ما يصفه
هؤلاء المتظاهرون في العاصمه ريفان بخذلان
بني قوميتهم والتسبب في ضياع الاقليم وهو
ما يدفعهم لمطالبه رئيس الوزراء نيكول
باشنيان بالاستقاله وهو من جهته يتهم
موسكو بالاخفاق في مهمه حفظ السلام في
كارباخ ويخرج في عيد الاستقلال على وقع
المظاهرات داعيا الى النظر للمستقبل ومسار
السلام الصعب
هذا المسار ليس سهلا فهو يمر بصدمات
خارجيه وداخليه لكن يجب ان نخوض هذا
المسار من اجل الاستقلال من اجل الدوله
ومن اجل المستقبل هل سيصمد سلامك رباخ
الاحدث امام تعقيدات الجغرافيا والسياسه
تجيب مقبلات الايام عن ذلك لكن على الارض
نفت وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه اتهامات
ارمينيه بانتهاك وقف اطلاق النار لكن قائد
فيلق القوات الاذربيجانيه اوقيل وفق مصدر
روسي لتورط بعض جنوده في قتل عناصر من قوه
حفظ السلام الروسيه اعتقل المشتبه بهم
وقدم الرئيس الاذربيجاني اعتذارا وعزاءا
لنظيره الروسي الذي سبق ان اكد على دور
قوات بلاده في حفظ السلام داخل الاقليم
متوقعا الوصول لتسويه سلميه للوضع هناك
هذا وكانت وسائل اعلام ارمينيه نقلت ساعه
عن رئيس الوزراء
انه لا ينوي الاستقاله على خلفيه الغضب
الشعبي من اتفاق ارمان كاراباخ مع
اذربيجان ويرى مراقبون ان غضب الشارع غير
قادر على تغيير المشهد السياسي وذلك في ظل
غياب معارضه حقيقيه
تبكي ذكرى ابنها الذي قتل في حرب كارباخ
قبل ثلاثه اعوام
لكن حزن جيان اليوم مختلف اذ يمتزج
بالحسره والالم على فقدان الابن والقضيه
معا كما تقول
تحولت مقبره في ريفان يوم عيد استقلال
ارمينيا الى وجهه لاسر وذوي ضحايا الحرب
من العسكريين احياء لذكراهم وذكرى ما ضحوا
من اجله فكل شيء هنا اصبح ذكرى
[تصفيق]
كالكثير من اهالي ابطال الحرب الذين ضحوا
من اجل ارساخ نحمل حكومتنا المسؤوليه بسبب
قراراتها وسياساتها تجاه الازمه الالم على
تسليم ارتساخ اليوم يضاهي الم على فقدان
ابني في الحرب
يؤكد رئيس الوزراء الارميني انه لا ينوي
الاستقاله على خلفيه ما جرى بعد ان ناى
باي دور لبلاده في اتفاق ارمني كراباخ مع
باكو تسارع المعارضه الى انشاء منصه وطنيه
تقول ان هدفها اقاله نيكولا
يزداد الضغط الشعبي على حكومه بشنيان التي
يحملونها وزر الخساره العسكريه ثم
السياسيه في اقليم كاراباخ ويترقب كثيرون
بقلق ما قد يحدثه الواقع الجديد من تغيرات
على الخريطه السياسيه داخل ارمينيا وفي
علاقاتها مع محيطها الاقليمي
تتعالى الاصوات الغاضبه في شوارع ريفان
ويزداد معها الضغط الشعبي على النخبه
الحاكمه يقلل مراقبون من قدره هذه
الاحتجاجات على التاثير في ظل غياب قوى
معارضه قادره على احداث تغيير في المشهد
السياسي
المعارضه في البرلمان لا تملك الاصوات
الكافيه لاقاله باشنيان وخارج البرلمان لا
توجد معارضه موحده لكن مع الضغط الشعبي
فقد حزب باشنيان الحاكم شعبيته
في ظل ازمه تمر بها العلاقات بين ارمينيا
وروسيا ينظر الى ان خساره يريفان سلطتها
على كاراباخ ستزيد من ذلك الجمود رغم ان
الاتفاق جرى برضا جميع الاطراف بما فيها
ارمينيا
في المنطقه تحدث الان تغيرات كبيره في
السابق كان السيد بوتين على سبيل المثال
قادرا على وقف اي تصعيد اقليمي باتصال
هاتفي واحد الان هناك لاعب مهم جديد وهو
تركيا المنطقه برايي تخرج رويدا رويدا من
الفضاء السوفيتي الى فضاء الشرق الاوسط
الكبير
يطوى اذا فصل رئيسي من ازمه كرباخ وتفتح
في المقابل فصول اخرى تعد بتحولات تلوح في
الافق لكنها قد لا تخرج عن نطاق التفاهم
والتنسيق المحكوم بمنطق المصالح
ام انغامي الجزيره يريفان
طلب الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس بعقد
مؤتمر دولي للسلام تشارك فيه كل الدول
المعنيه بالسلام في الشرق الاوسط وفي
كلمته امام الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده
دعا لاتخاذ خطوات عمليه تستند لقرارات
الشرعيه الدوليه للاعتراف بدوله فلسطين
لم يبقى امامنا سوى الطلب اليكم
عقد مؤتمر دولي للسلام صعبه
عقد مؤتمر دولي لسلام تشارك فيه جميع
الدول المعنيه بتحقيق السلام في الشرق
الاوسط بشكل عام ولذلك فانني اطلب من
منظمتكم الموقره ومن الامين العام السيد
انطونيو
وضع الترتيبات والدعوه الى انعقاد هذا
المؤتمر
الذي قد يكون الفرصه الاخيره
هذه اخر فرصه
لابقاء حل الدولتين ممكننا
ولمنع تدهور الاوضاع بشكل اكثر خطوره
ما يهدد امن واستقرار منطقتنا والعالم
اجمع
اطالب منظمتكم والامين العام
بتنفيذ قرارات توفير الحمايه للشعب
الفلسطيني
حمايه نريد الحمايه
نريد من يحمينا من الاحتلال
من العدوان
المتواصل لجيش الاحتلال والمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين الارهابيين
ودعم توجهنا للمحاكم والجهات الدوليه
ذات الاختصاص لان الوضع القائم
لم يعد محتملا
مستمرون معكم في الحسد وفي العناوين
مع تواصل عمليات انتشار الجثث والبحث عن
الاف المفقودين في درنا السلطات الليبيه
تؤكد ان الوضع الصحي تحت السيطره وتنفي
رصد اي امراض معديه ومنظمه الهجره الدوليه
تحسن نزوح اكثر من 43 الفا
وفي المغرب تكثيف عمليه اغاثه المنكوبين
بعد نحو اسبوعين على زلزال الحوز والسلطات
وصلوا جهود تنفيذ البرنامج العاجل لايواء
المتضررين واعاده الاعمار
بالتزامن مع لقاء بايدن وزيلينسكي البيت
الابيض يعلن تزويد اوكرانيا بقدرات كبيره
للدفاع الجوي في تطورات الميدان هجوم
صاروخي ضد البنى التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا وكيف تعلن استهداف قاعده جويه
روسيه في القرن
وغدا توقف اطلاق النار في اقليم كاراباخ
توافق بين اذربيجان وارمن الاقليم على
التفاوض ومطالب بضمانات امنيه لاهالي
كرباخ قبل التخلي عن الاسلحه والرئيس
الوزراء الارمينيه يتهم روسيا بالاخفاق في
مهمه حفظ السلام
اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه نزوها اكثر من
43 الف شخص من درنه الى مناطق ليبيه اخرى
وذلك بسبب عاصفه دانيال المدمره ومن جهتها
اعلنت السلطات تقسيمه دارنا وفق الاضرار
التي نجمت عن العاصفه وذلك لتسهيل عمل فرق
الانقاذ وفي ظروف صعبه للغايه تستمر
عمليات انتشار الجثث ورفع الانقاض في
المناطق المنكوبه وسط تضاؤل الامل للعثور
عن نجي
فاجعه الدرن التي تكبر مع كل رقم جديد
للقتله والمنكوبين والمفقودين بلغت
الماساه درجه اصبحت فيها اقصى الامنيات
العثور على جثه قريب لاكرامه بالدفن
من البعض خلال الايام الاولى للماساه في
مقابر جماعيه دون تحديد هويتهم ويعقد مهمه
البعض لمعرفه مصير ذويهم ابتلع البحر
الكثير منهم وتحاول فرق الانقاذ في ظروف
صعبه انتشال الجثث عائلات باكملها لم يعد
لها وجود ولا لما كانت يوما بيوتهم اعلنت
السلطه الليبيه تقسيم المدينه وفق الاضرار
التي لحقت باحيائها تنص الخطه على اخلاء
الاحياء الاكثر تضررا من سكانها لتسهيل
عمل فرق الانقاذ وحمايه الناجين من انتشار
الامراض تستعد منظمه الصحه العالميه لاي
طارئ وتواصل فرقها جهودها لتوفير
المستلزمات الطبيه والمساعدات للمناطق
المائيه في محيط الدرنه مع معالي الوزير
اتفقنا اليوم انه يكون في تقريبا
شراكه بين فرق المنظمه
وفرق الوز
[موسيقى]
ومن جانبه قال وزير الصحه الليبي في
الحكومه المكلفه من البرلمان عثمان عبد
الجليل ان الوضع الصحي في درنه مستقر وسط
جهود عالميه للتخفيف من وطاه الكارثه واكد
عبد الجليل الحرصه على استخدام الطرق
العلميه السليمه في التعامل مع الكارثه
يعني هناك مستشفيات ميدانيه موجوده كل
الخدمات الصحيه يتم تقديمها للمواطنين
اعتقد لو فيه قصور يكون
جزئي او في بعض الاشياء يعني وهذه نسحوا
لتوفيرها لكن معظم الخدمات الاساسيه
موجوده والحمد لله اليوم مازلنا في تطوير
للموضوع هذا
وينضم الان الينا من تونس التوحيد باشا
مدير المنظمه الدوليه للهجره التابعه
للامم المتحده في ليبيا اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
توحيد اذا هذا الرقم الذي اعلنته منظمه
الصحه العالميه
نزوح اكثر من ثلاثه واربعين الف شخص من
درنه كيف تابعتموه
الرقم
43 الف هو من صدر عنا المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده استنادا الى
مصادرنا والاشخاص الذين يعملون في الارض
ومنظمه الصحه العالميه نقلت وفاه اربعه
الاف شخص استنادا الى مصادر المستشفيات
على اي حال الوضع صعب هناك حوالي 30 الف
من النازحين ربما البعض اصبح ذلك اصبح
اربعين الف والان صار اكثر من 43 الف لان
الناس بداوا يغادرون دارنا الى مدن
المجاوره مثل طبرق الى الشرق والى الغرب
باتجاه بنغازي وبعضهم حتى وصل الى طرابلس
ايضا ولكننا سمعنا وزير الصحه في الحكومه
المكلفه من البرلمان يقول ان الوضع الصحي
في الواقع مستقر وان الامور بدات تعود الى
طبيعتها الى اي حد
يؤثر او يعني كيف نفهم اذا هذا العدد
الكبير الذي
يترك درنا
وهذا
نحن اجرينا نقاشا مع وزير الصحه ايضا
وفي الحقيقه هم مؤسسوا مستشفى ميداني في
دارنا والاخبار الساره ان ليبيا لديها
اشخاص من ذوي الخبره الصحيه من الاطباء
والمريضين ذهبوا الى تلك المنطقه ما قال
لنا وزير الصحه هو ان هناك حاجات خاصه مثل
المعاناه من الصدمه الذين التي عانى منها
كثيرون وحتى العاملون الصحيون
اضافه الى الحاجه الى خبراء في الصحه
النفسيه ايضا وما نفهمه هو ان الوضع في
دارنا لان درنا لم تعد مدينه صالحه للعيش
واضطر سكانها الى النزوح الى مناطق اخرى
علينا ان نتابع حاجات هنا قد تكون حاجات
صحيه او حاجات من نوع اخر ربما الحاجه الى
الاسره الى
وسائل النظافه الى الملابس كل هذه الامور
نحن نبحث فيها لنرى ماذا يمكننا ان نقدم
لهم
الذين نزحوا بالفعل كيف تقدرون يعني حجم
المساعدات التي يحتاجونها خصوصا للذين
يتوزعون في مدن الجوار وكم تتوقعون ان
تطول فتره نزوحهم
نعم سؤال جيد فعلا
علينا ان نعمل مع السلطات الليبيه هم
يريدون ان يضمنوا ان الناس يجب ان ينتقلوا
الى سكن دائم وصالح
واذا اذا لم يستطيعوا العوده الى منازلهم
فورا في دارنا لهذا السبب هؤلاء
تنقلوا في مناطق مختلفه في شرق ليبيا ونحن
لدينا قوائم باماكن
تواجدهم ووفقا للبيانات المتاحه لنا
منظمات الاغاثه الدوليه وتابع الامم
المتحده وغيرها تحاول
معرفه اين هؤلاء وتقيم حاجاتهم لنرى ماذا
يمكن ان نقدم لهم من احتياجاتهم واود ايضا
ان اقول في اعقاب هذه الكارثه المريعه نحن
كلنا نقف سويه مع السكان الليبيين
والسلطات لنعمل ما نستطيع لكي نضمن ان
حاجيات هؤلاء الناس خاصه الحاجات الضروريه
يتم تلبيتها اشكرك توحيد باشا من تونس
مدير المنظمه الدوليه الهجره التابعه
للامم المتحده في ليبيا شكرا
[موسيقى]
الان الى المغرب تتوصل لعمليات اغاثه
المنكوبين بعد نحو اسبوعين من زلزال الحوس
في الاثناء تواصلوا السلطات الجهود لتنفيذ
البرنامج العاجل لاواء المتضررين واعاده
الاعمار وقالت وزاره الصحه ان عدد الجرح
الذين تكفلت بهم وزاره الصحه بلغ سته عشر
الفا وسته وسبعين شخصا
كما اكد المتحدث باسم الحكومه المغربيه ان
فاجعه الزلزال تطلب التدخل الدوله في
مختلف مؤسساتها ومصالحها من اجل مساعده
المتضررين واضاف ان المرحله القادمه تقتضي
البناء واعاده الحياه الى المناطق
المتضرره بسرعه
وفعاليه ونجاعه
المرحله الاولى اللي كانت فيها صعوبات
اللي كان فيها الم اللي كان فيها يعني
واحد النوع ديال الحزن الحمد لله الجميع
تعبئ الان مشينا المرحله الثانيه هي مرحله
البناء هي مرحله كيفاش نعيد الحياه لهذه
المناطق كلها المتضرره بسرعه ولكن ماشي
فقط السرعه ولكن ايضا بفعاليه وبنجاعه
وباش هاد المناطق هادي تكون عندها واحد
القدره على انها تملك مقومات اقتصاديه
حقيقيه من اجل ان تساهم واحد المساهمه
كبيره في النتيجه الداخلي الخام وهاد
الناس هادو يعيشوا في كرامه
نعم واكيد ان
الخطاب ان البلاغ الدوى الملكي كان واضحا
بالامس وهو اننا اولا خرجنا من وضعيه الان
دخلنا الى وضعيه البناء بناء الانسان
وبناء التعمير واعتقد ان البلاغ الدوال
الملكي كان واضحا واي كارثه اي مشروع يجب
ان تتوفر فيه ثلاثه شروط الموارد الماليه
الموارد الاوستيكيه الاراده السياسيه ثم
ثم الموارد اللوجستيكيه الان من خلال بلاغ
الدول الملكي المغرب الان وفر الموارد
الماليه وهي مهمه جدا
120 مليار درهم اي موازي 120 مليار دولار
الان الموارد البشريه متوفره وخصوصا انها
تضم مغاربه من الداخل ومن خارج المغرب
الاراده السياسيه واضحه مادام ان هذا
مشروع يرعاه ملك البلاد فكل نجاح
متوفره كل نسب النجاح متوفره فالان اعتقد
منذ الامس دخلنا في عمليه حاسمه وهو اعاده
البناء لكن هذا البناء لن يكون اعتباطيا
بل الملكي حدد ثلاث شروط الشرط الاول هو
التواصل
والانصات للسكان المحليين ثانيا احترام
البعد البيئي ثالثا احترام خصوصيه هذه
المنطقه ان على مستوى اللغوي او المستوى
الثقافي او الهويه اعتقد ان المغرب اليوم
وفر كل الشروط لانجاح هذا المشروع لانه
كما نجح
في تجاوز
وتحديات جائحه كورونا اليوم المغرب ملكا
وشعبا وحكومه قادرون على اعاده الحياه الى
هذه المناطق في اقرب وقت ولكن بواقعيه
ولكن
اذا سمحت لي ولكن هذه الظروف ايضا
ساعدت على تسليط الضوء على اوضاع وبنيه
تحتيه تكاد تكون يعني متاخره جدا في هذه
المناطق الى اي حد سيتم النظر في اعاده
ربما
جدوله الاولويات فيما يتعلق بالمناطق
المحيطه والنائيه والتي ربما كان الوضع
العام فيها
سبب هذا الضرر الكبير
لا مو صحيح لا احد من ابناء الشعب المغربي
حتى صاحب الجلاله يعني لا يؤمن ان هناك
فشل نسبي في السياسات العموميه بهذا
المناطق هذه من المسلمات اليوم المغرب
هناك زمن الذي
تتبع فيه مساطر المحاسبه لان الدستور
المغربي واضح ربط المسؤوليه بالمحاسبه
الان الاولويات
العاجله هي الانقاذ هي البناء هي تقديم
المساعدات
ووفق معايير الدوليه
ففعلا اننا اليوم اكتشفنا ان اسباب هذا
الزلزال هي متعدده ولكن يجب ان لا نبقى
يعني ننتقد اليوم يجب ان نتحول الى البناء
وزمن المحاسبه لابد ان يكون على كل وفق كل
معطيات المتوفره الان ان هذا المنطقه شكرا
ستخرج من منطقه من واحد وضعيه معينه الى
وضعيه اكثر اكثر
هيكله
تنميه لانها ستستفيد من هذا الدعم الاساسي
شكرا لكم القاضي رئيس المرصد المغربي
لدراسات الاستراتيجيه والسياسيه من الرباط
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه اذا لم
يتم الوقوف مع اوكرانيا فلن تكون هناك اي
دوله في العالم في مامن وخلال لقائه نظيره
الاوكراني في البيت الابيض اضاف بايدينا
ان شجاعه الاوكرانيين في الدفاع عن حريتهم
ومبادئهم الهمت العالم بحسب تعبيره وفي
المقابل عبر زيلينسكي عن تقديره للمساعده
التي تقدمها الولايات المتحده لبلاده في
مكافحه الارهاب الروسي كما وصفه مشيرا الى
انه اجرى حوارا وصفه بالصريح مع اعضاء
الكونجرس وانه سيركز في نقاشاته مع بايدن
على الحاجه الاوكرانيه لاسلحه الدفاع
الجوي
سيعلن الرئيس بايدن اليوم الحزمه جديده من
المساعدات العسكريه تتضمن قدرات دفاع جوي
كبيره لمساعده اوكرانيا على حمايه شعبها
هذه القدرات ستساعد اوكرانيا على تعزيز
دفاعاتها قبل الشتاء يرجح ان يكون قاسيا
ومليئا بهجمات روسيه متجدده على البنيه
التحتيه الحيويه الاوكرانيه ستحرم ابرياء
من مستلزمات كالتدفئه والكهرباء وبما ان
الرئيس بوتين غير قادر على تحقيق اهدافه
في ساحه المعركه فانه يلجا الى هجمات تهدف
الى اغراق السكان العاديين في البرد
والظلام ونعمل مع الاوكرانيين لتعقيد تلك
المهمه على روسيا
وفي التطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا قال
الجيش الاوكرانيين دفاعاته تصدت لسته
وثلاثين صاروخا روسيا من اصل 43 عشرون
منها في هجوم على العاصمه اسفر عن اصابه
سبعه مدنيين وتضرر عدد من المباني
والمنشات تتزايد المخاوف الاوكرانيه من
الارتفاع الهجمات الروسيه على منشات
الطاقه خصوصا مع اقتراب فصل الشتاء
يزداد ذوي القصف في اوكرانيا بشكل غير
مسبوق فالحرب هناك تدخل مرحله جديده من
التصعيد والامر حسب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
نفسها اصبح مرعبا سماء اوكرانيا شهدت 43
صاروخا روسيا في هجمات متواصله تقول قياده
الاركان الاوكرانيه متحدثه عن اسقاط 36
منها
العاصمه كييف وحدها استهدفت ب 20 صاروخا
ما اسفر عن اصابه عده اشخاص وتضرر مباني
ومنشات مختلفه القصف طال مقاطعه شركه
جنوبي كييف ايضا وفي غربي اوكرانيا تعرضت
مقاطعه ريفني لهجوم مشابه اصاب منشاه
للطاقه ما ادى الى انقطاع التيار
الكهربائي عن نحو 400 مدينه وقريه بينها
مناطق في مقاطعه كييف اما في الفيف غربان
فقد سقط صاروخان على منطقه ما ادى الى
تدمير منشاه صناعيه ومخزن
الهجوم الروسي الكثيف خصوصا على منشات
الطاقه يجعل الصوره اكثر تهديدا اذ حضرت
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه من اشهر وصفتها
بالصعبه في اعقاب الهجوم فمع قرب حلول فصل
الشتاء تخشى السلطات في كييف تكرار روسيا
استراتيجيه اعتمدتها عام 2022 وقامت
بالاساس على استهداف منشات الطاقه من اجل
قطع الكهرباء والتدفئه عن السكان وللمره
الاولى منذ سته اشهر تضررت منشات للطاقه
في غرب اوكرانيا ووسطها ورغم اعتراض
القوات الاوكرانيه غالبيه الصواريخ حسب
اعلانها الا ان عددا منها حقق اصابات
مباشره على الارض في مقابل الهجمات
الروسيه اعلن جهاز الامن المركزي
الاوكراني توجيه ضربه للقوات الروسيه في
مطار ساك العسكري في شبه جزيره القرم وهو
احدث هجوم على المنطقه الواقعه على البحر
الاسود والتي تعهدت كييف باستعادتها في
مقابل ذلك اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
استمرار اف شالها لما تعهدت به اوكرانيا
عبر تدمير 19 طائره مسيره اوكرانيه فوق
شبه جزيره القرن واكدت ان قواتها اسقطت
ايضا ثلاثه طائرات مسيره فوق مقاطعات
وينضم الان الينا من موسكو اندريه
المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجي كذلك ينضم
الينا من واشنطن
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي اهلا
بكما معنا في الحصاد ابدا معك سيد لاري
كورب واضح ان زيلنسكي يعني يعول على هذه
المساعدات الامريكيه ولكن مع ارتفاع اصوات
الجمهوريين في الكونغرس تقول الى متى
سنمول هذه الحرب
ومع قرب السنه الانتخابيه هل يمكن ان
تتغير استراتيجيه الولايات المتحده بخصوص
الاندفاع بالتزويد العسكري والمالي الى
نوع من
الحل الدبلوماسي
في الحقيقه نحن ما نسميه
بمجموعه الحريه وهي مجموعه مجموعه الصلبه
من اليمين في الحزب الجمهوري اذا ما حصلوا
على ما يريدون ربما تتاثر الامور اليوم
بالاجتماع بينسكي والرئيس بايدن وحديث
امام الكونغرس رئيس مالوس النواب مكارسي
هو ايضا رفع صوته
يتحدث عن مئات المليارات من الدعم الذي
نقدمه لاوكرانيا
باين النظره او باي عين تنظر موسكو لزياره
الى واشنطن
من وجهه نظر وموسكو ليس هناك اي فرق بين
زياره
لواشنطن او بقائه في كييف لانه في روسيا
هناك راي عام بانسكي هو ليس الطرف او
المحركات الرئيسي لكل ما يحصل
وبالتالي فهذا مجرد نوع من العمل
الاستعراضي ولا يعني اي شيء حقيقي
من ناحيته نظر سياسيه او عسكريه
ربما في الحديث على ان بوتين يراهن على
الصبر الاستراتيجي الروسي والسؤال هو على
ماذا تراهن واشنطن هنا
من حيث الاساس واشنطن
تعتمد على تماسك التحالف الدعم لاوكرانيا
نعم الولايات المتحده هي التي تقود هذا
التحالف لكن هناك اربعين دوله تساهم
بالمال والمعدات وراينا يتوسع ولدينا
دولتين جديدتين تقدمان هي المزيد من
الدعم اذا واشنطن تعتمد على او على
استمرار هذا التحالف الذي اسس قبل نحو
عامين طالما نستطيع هل المحافظه على ذلك
نعم ولكن هل كل هذا الدعم
اذا سمحتي
اذا سمحتي هنا هل كل هذا الدعم فعلا يعني
حقق
التقدم الذي ارادته واشنطن بعد كل ما حصل
كيف يمكن وصف ما تم تحقيقه على الارض من
الجانب الاوكراني مع كل هذه المساعدات
اعتقد ان هذا الدعم مضرر وربما لم نحقق كل
ما كنا نرجو كنا نرجو لو ان الهجوم
الاوكرانيا المضاد حقق نتائج افضل لكن
هناك تقدم بطيء ونحن نحاول ان نظهر بان ان
اذا لم نستطع ايقاف الحرب فعلينا ان
نستطيع ايقاف قصرهم للمدن على الاقل كما
فعلوا اليوم ونحاول
الوقف هذه الحرب وان تدرك روسيا بان
اوكرانيا ليست جزءا منها وانها اذا ما
غازتها مره اخرى سيكون هناك رد فعل من حلف
النيتو سيد
واضح ان هناك تكثيف للقصف الان شهدناه
اليوم ولكن الى اي حد فعلا يمكن ان يكون
فصل الشتاء نوع من المغير هنا للمعادله
بحيث تجبر
موسكو على ربما العوده الاستراتيجياتها في
2022 ضرب المنشات منشات الطاقه الامر الذي
تتحسب له كيف
من وجهه نظر اقتصاديه
فان
ان هذه الحرب
مهمه جدا للطرفين واعتقد
انظمه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه على وشك الانهيار واذا ما وصلت
روسيا هجماتها الصاروخيه على على منشات
الطاقه
الاوكرانيه فان ذلك
وجه ضربه قويه لقدرات الاوكرانيه على
القتال وعلى استمرار
حياتها الاقتصاديه وما الى ذلك
وكذلك
اعتقد ان هناك اعتماد كبير على الجو
كان هناك جو غير طبيعي كان الجو دافئا جدا
وبالتالي اما اذا شتاء القادم
وصلت الدرجات البروده الى الدرجه
الاعتياديه بين بروده كبيره جدا او منخفضه
جدا سيؤثر على المعنويات والقدرات
الاوكرانيه
الامن القومي الامريكي يتحدث عن ان هذه
الحزمه الجديده او الدفعه الجديده من
المساعدات الامريكيه
ستعزز دفاعات اوكرانيا قبل فصل الشتاء
ما تعليقك على هذا اولا
ان النوعيه والكميه الحقيقيه لمساعدات
الامريكيه العسكريه لاوكرانيا وخاصه دعمها
للدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه ليست
انها لا تغطي كل الاحتياجات الاوكرانيه
ولا اعتقد ان هذه التجهيزات
ستغير
كثيرا قدرات اوكرانيا على الهجوم ومواجهه
الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه
عدم موافقه الجمهوريين في الكونجرس على
التزويد اوكرانيا بما تحتاجه في هذه
المرحله الى اي حد فعلا سيؤثر هذا على
موقف اوكرانيا في الحرب
لو ان الولاه المتحده توقفت عن دعمها واضح
ان هذا سيجعل اكثر صعوبه لاوكرانيا
الاستمرار في التقدم الذي حققوه منذ بدءهم
بالهجوم المضاد لم يحققوا التقدم الذي
يرغبون فيه لكن روسيا خسرت حوالي 10% من
الاراضي الاوكرانيه التي
استولت عليها لكن هذا يبقى في حكم الاقليه
الوقت المتحده لدي فيها وجهات نظر مختلفه
واذا ما القيتم نظره على الصور التي
امامكم ترون
الرئيس مرسي الذواب مكارسي وزعيم
الديمقراطين
الدعم من كلا الحزبين
مستمر طالما ان الشعب الاوكراني قادر على
تحمل هذه التضحيات
واشنطن تحاول تحقيق هدف قد يكون مستحيلا
عدا عن ذلك اعلى العموم ما اشكرك لاريكورد
مساعد وزير الدفاع الامريكي السابق وكبير
الباحثين في مركز التقدم الامريكي واشكر
من موسكو اندريه
المحلل العسكري والاستراتيجي
وكما ذكرنا في انتظار كلمه والمؤتمر
الصحفي
وبعيدن شكرا لك
نحو 600 يوم من الحرب زمن كاف للقول ان
روسيا اخفقت في ادراك نصر حاسم كانت تتطلع
اليه وزمن كاف ايضا للتساؤل ان كان ثمه
تململ داخل المعسكر الحليف لكيف من طول
امد الحرب يصل الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
ميرزيلنسكي الى واشنطن طلبا لتعهد من رئيس
بايدن بان يبقي على زخم دعمه العسكري لكيف
لكن زياره زيلينسكي هذه المره وهي الثانيه
له منذ الحرب تختلف عن سابقتها اذ بات
الخصوم الجمهوريون لبايض يمسكون بالغالبيه
في مجلس النواب وعليه فان الرئيس
الاوكراني لن يحظى هذه المره باستقبال
احتفالي في مبنى الكابيتول كما جرى في عهد
الديمقراطيين
ابت تصاعدوا اصوات داخل الكونجرس يقودها
الجمهوريون لفرد رقابه على الاموال
المغلقه على اوكرانيا يقول زعيم الغالبيه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب كيفن مكارتي ان
لديه اسئله يريد طرحها على زيلينسكي بشان
مصير الاموال الامريكيه والسبيل لتحقيق
الانتصار تقود الولايات المتحده تحالف
رامشتاين الذي يضم 50 دوله بمثاق ينص على
الدعم العسكري لا محدود لاوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا منذ الرابع والعشرين من
يناير 2022 وحتى يونيو الماضي تتجاوز
التقديرات بالدعم الغربي لكييف 166 مليار
دولار
48% من هذا الدعم كان لاغراض عسكريه على
علاقه بميدان الحرب اما الباقي فكان دعما
ماليا لحكومه زيلانسكي ومساعدات انسانيه
80 مليار دولار هي قيمه الدعم العسكري
الغربي من الخوذ والدروع الواقيه من
الرصاص ويبدو ان المؤتمر الصحفي للرئيسين
الامريكي والاوكراني قد بدا بالفعل الى
واشنطن
نستمر بدعم جهود اوكرانيا في تحقيق سلام
دائما يحفظ سلامه اراضي اوكرانيا روسيا
لوحدها روسيا لوحدها التي تعترض سبيل
السلام اليوم بدلا من وقف الحرب تسعى
روسيا للحصول على المزيد من السلاح من
ايران ومن كوريا ورغم قرارات مجلس الامن
التي
ساهمت موسكو في تمريرها بدلا من ذلك
والنجاعه التي تهدد الكثير من العائلات في
العالم تستمر روسيا بعملياتها الخطف خطفت
روسيا الاف الاطفال الاوكرانيين وتستمر
بالقصف وتستمر ايضا ومع بدايه فصل الشتاء
روسيا مره اخرى ستستخدم
الفصل الشتاء كالسلاحي ضد الشعب الاوكراني
لكن كما قال الرئيس
اننا كما قلت له الولايات المتحده ستستمر
في الوقوف الى جانبهم سوف
نمرر حزمه مساعداتنا في ذلك ذخائر ومدفعيه
والدبابات وفي الاسبوع المقبل سيتم ايصال
بعض هذه الدبابات اضافه الى
تقديمي
الدعم في مجال المضادات الجويه لحمايه
المنشات الحيويه التي
توفر الطاقه والكهرباء هذا اضافه الى
ايصال منظومات هوك وغيرها في
الاشهر القادمه
وستكون هناك ايضا
حزمه من المعدات التي ستحمي
الاغذيه ومنشات الطاقه
وغيرها وكما ساعدنا ونلتزم بمساعده الشعب
الاوكراني الان نحن ملتزمون بدعمهم في
اعاده الاعمار ومحاربه الفساد
وتحقيق بيئه مناسبه
للاستثمار في مجال المال والاعلام اي سيد
اعمال عفوا ايها السيدات
والساده ارحب بك ابن مره اخرى وهي عفوا هي
ستكون مندوبه امريكا الخاصه في مجال
التعافي واعاده الاعمار
ومساعدتهم في مجال الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه
هذا الى جانبي 29 من شركائنا
الملتزمون بمساعده اوكرانيا لكي تبدا تضمن
المستقبل وتحافظ على حريتها وسلامه
اراضيها هذا هو كل ما يتعلق به الارض
المستقبل المستقبل الحريه امريكا لن تتخلى
ابدا ولن تنعى بنفسها عن ذلك ابدا وبعد
مضيء 575 يوما ما زلنا
متمسكون بالالتزام بالدفاعنا وسنبقى معكم
وسنستمر في دعمنا معكم شكرا فخامه الرئيس
شكرا لوقوفكم الى جانب على مدى 575 يوما
كل هذه الايام وقفتم الى جانبنا نحن
الاوكرانيين وكلنا جميعا نشكرك ونشكر
فريقك ونشكر الكونجرس ونشكره وسال الاعلام
لدعمكم والرسائل التي تنقلوها عن الحقيقه
وحول هذه الكارثه وهذا العدوان من جانب
روسيا اذا شكرا جزيلا لك فخامه الرئيس
بايدن
ولهذا
لهذه اللقاءات البداءه اليوم حققنا نتائج
مهمه وايضا
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالعمل على مستقبلي
اوكرانيا والقرارات الاستراتيجيه التي
ستساعدنا على حمايه انفسنا من اي عدوان
مستقبلين علينا وعلى شعبنا وهذا سيكون
اعلانات مجموعه السبع
وترتيباتنا الثنائيه وثانيا الاتفاقات
التي توصلنا لها
اليها في مجال
التعزيز قدراتنا الدفاعيه والتي سيتم
الاعلان عنها قريبا اعتقد ان اننا طبعا
المتحده ونشكركم فخامه الرئيس على حزمه
المساعدات الدفاعيه القويه جدا لاوكرانيا
وهي تماما ما يحتاجه جنودنا الان رابعا
المتحده ستساعد اوكرانيا لتعزيز دفاعاتنا
الجويه في فصل الشتاء وخامسا اتخذنا بعض
الخطوات
لتوسيع نطاق تصدير الحبوب من اوكرانيا
وسوف نستمر في العمل
على صيغه السلام
والترتيب
لقمه قادمه اذا شكرا ليس لهذه النقاط التي
ذكرته بل لكل الايام الخمسمائه وخمسه
وسبعين التي وقفتم بها الى جانبنا شكرا
جزيلا
هل انتم واثقون من سوف يدعم جهودكم في
تقديم الدعم لاوكرانيا
انا
ساعتمد على حسن الحكم والشعور بحسن الحكم
على الامور في صفوف الكونغرس الامريكي
شكرا جزيلا لكم
اذا في ختام الاجتماع الذي عقد بين
الرئيسين الامريكي والاوكراني في البيت
الابيض واضح ان الرئيس الامريكي لم يكن
راغبا في اخذ اي اسئله من الصحفيين سيتوجه
مباشره الى وجده التي تقف امام البيت
الابيض
وجد واضح ان ربما كنا نتوقع شيء من
المداخلات ولكن الرئيس الامريكي انهى
الموضوع باعلانه حزمه المساعدات وتعليق
ايضا تفضلي
هذا صحيح ليلى الرئيس لانسكي هنا في البيت
الابيض منذ اكثر من ساعتين حقيقه
وما اعلنه الرئيس الامريكي قبل قليل وهو
ارسال حزمه مساعدات دفاعيه جديده
لاوكرانيا هو في اطار القضايا التي نقشت
خلال وجود زيلينسكي هنا ولكن ايضا هناك
قضيه الاربع وعشرين مليار دولار وهو
السؤال الذي طرح على الرئيس الامريكي ما
اذا كان واثقا من ان الكونجرس سوف يصادق
او يوافق على منح الاداره البيت الابيض
هذا المبلغ من اجل تغطيه المساعدات
الامنيه لاوكرانيا للعام القادم البيت
الابيض يرغب بان يتم ارسال او الموافقه
الكونجرس على هذه الاموال بحلول الاول من
ديسمبر ولكن هناك اصوات من
الجمهوريين تعارض ارسال هذه الاموال
لاوكرانيا وبدات بطرح تساؤلات حول يعني
جدوى مواصله ارسال كل هذه الاموال اكثر من
112 مليار دولار ليله تم انفاقها حتى
اليوم خلال ال19 شهرا من ايام الحرب
الروسيه الى اوكرانيا بالنسبه للرئيس
بايدن كما سمعناه يقول قبل قليل فان
اوكرانيا لم تنكسر رغم طول امد هذه الحرب
وبان الرئيس بوتين كان مخطئا بان اوكرانيا
سوف تنكسر اكد بان الاداره الامريكيه تدعم
جهود السلام التوصل الى اتفاق سلاما في
اوكرانيا على ان يكون دائما وعادلا في
اوكرانيا ويحترم سياده اوكرانيا على
اراضيها لكنه حمل روسيا مسؤوليه عدم
الرغبه بالسلام وقائلا انها بدلا من انهاء
الحرب تذهب وتتوجه الى ايران وكوريا
الشماليه من اجل
الحصول على المزيد من الاسلحه ضرب
الاوكرانيين نقطه ايضا قالها الرئيس بايدن
ليلى وهو ان الاسبوع المقبل سوف تتسلم
اوكرانيا اول دفعه من دبابات ابرامز هذه
الدبابات كان طلبها الرئيس الاوكراني
العام الماضي هي تتطلب تدريبات مكثفه
للجيش الاوكراني من اجل ليس فقط توجيه هذه
الدبابات ولكن ايضا من اجل عمليات الصيانه
لهذه الدبابات اذا الاسبوع المقبل سوف
تتسلم اوكرانيا اول دفعه من هذه الصواريخ
ليله اشكرك وجد وقفي من امام البيت الابيض
شكرا جزيلا لك
عقد مجلس الامن الدولي جلسه طارئه ومفتوحه
بشان تطورات في اقليم كارابا وقال الامين
العام المساعد لاوروبا واسيا الوسطى
والامريكيتين ميروسلاف جينكا في احاطته ان
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
استئناف الاعمال العدائيه مؤخرا والذي ادى
الى خسائر ماساويه في ارواح المدنيين ودعا
جينكا الى وقف موثوق ودائما لجميع الاعمال
العدائيه واكدا ان من شان اي تصعيد متجدد
اي يؤدي الى مزيد من الخسائر في الارواح
والمعانات الانسانيه والى المزيد من
انتكاسه جهود السلام المدعومه دوليا ومن
جانبها قالت المندوبه الامريكيه في مجلس
الامن الدولي لندن سكرين فيلد ان اذربيجان
تتحمل مسؤوليه ضمان امتثال قواتها بشكل
صارم للقانون الدولي
هذا وكانت الجوله الاولى من المحادثات بين
طرفي الصراع والتي انعقدت في يفلاغ في
اذربيجان برعايه روسيه قد انتهت وصفت
الرئاسه اذربيجانيه لاجتماع بالبناء وقالت
انه تمت مناقشه قضايا اعاده ادماج السكان
الارمن في الاقليم وتنظيم العمل وفقا
لدستوري وقوانين جمهوريه اي اذربيجان خلال
الاجتماع ومن جهه قلم مستشار وزعيمي ارمن
اقليم كاراباخ ان العمل ما زال جاريا على
تفاصيل الاتفاق منها تلك المتعلقه بتسليم
السلاح اما في ارمينيا فقد اتهم رئيس
الوزراء نيك روسيا بالاخفاق في مهمه حفظ
السلام في اقليم كرمخ
اجواء ايجابيه هكذا وصف بيان الرئاسه
الاذربيجانيه الجوله الاولى من المحادثات
مع ارمن اقليم كرباخ طرحت وفق البيان في
محادثات مدينه افلاخ غرب العاصمه باكو
ملفات اعاده دمج ارمن كاراباخ وترميم بنيه
الاقليم التحتيه وتنظيم العمل وفق الدستور
والقوانين في اذربيجان علقت اذا ما وصفت
قبل يومين بعمليه مكافحه الارهاب التي
بداها وانهاها الجيش الاذربيجاني وهي سرعه
قياسيه بالنظر لتاريخ جولات الصراع حول
الاقليم بين اذربيجان وارمينيا تباها بها
يوم الاربعاء الرئيس الهام علياف معلنا
تحقيق كل اهداف العمليه لكن ارمن كاراباخ
الطرف الثاني في العمليه قالوا ان العمل
ما زال جاريا على تفاصيل الاتفاق وخاصه
مساله تسليم السلاح التي قال مستشار
زعيمهم ديفيد بابيان انها ما زالت بحاجه
وان الضمانات الامنيه التي سيحصل عليها
الارمن غير معروفه مؤكدا على عدم رغبه
مواطنه في العيش كجزء من اذربيجان ذاك حلم
كان الارمن يرقبونه من قديم ولكن بدعم
اقليمي وتحديدا من موسكو اليوم يرون ان
الجميع خذلهم بمن فيهم روسيا بل وحتى
ارمينيا نفسها فضلا عن الغرب ارمينيا
الحاضنه العرقيه الاقرب لارمن كاراباخ
تلام داخليا على نطاق واسع على ما يصيفه
هؤلاء المتظاهرون في العاصمه ريفان بخذلان
بني قوميتهم والتسبب في ضياع الاقليم وهو
ما يدفعهم لمطالبه رئيس الوزراء نيكول
باشنيان بالاستقاله وهو من جهته يتهم
موسكو بالاخفاق في مهمه حفظ السلام في
كاراباخ ويخرج في عيد الاستقلال على وقع
المظاهرات داعيا الى النظر للمستقبل ومسار
السلام الصعب
هذا المسار ليس سهلا فهو يمر صدمات خارجيه
وداخليه لكن يجب ان نخوض هذا المسار من
اجل الاستقلال من اجل الدوله ومن اجل
المستقبل هل سيصمد سلامك رباخ الاحدث امام
تعقيدات الجغرافيا والسياسه تجيب مقبلات
الايام عن ذلك لكن على الارض نفت وزاره
الدفاع الاذربيجانيه اتهامات ارمينيه
بانتهاك وقف اطلاق النار لكن قائد فيلق
القوات الاذربيجانيه اقيل وفق مصدر روسي
لتورط بعض جنوده في قتل عناصر من قوه حفظ
السلام الروسيه اعتقل المشتبه بهم وقدم
الرئيس الاذربيجاني اعتذارا وعزاء لنظيره
الروسي الذي سبق ان اكد على دور قوات
بلاده في حفظ السلام داخل الاقليم متوقعا
الوصول لتسويه سلميه للوضع هناك
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن ترودو ان
مقتله زعيم من السيخ في كندا امر خطير
وعلى الحكومه الهنديه العمل مع كندا لكشف
الحقيقه وانجاز العداله وفي نيودلهي اعلنت
الخارجيه الهنديه تعليقه اصدار التاشيرات
للمواطنين الكنديين في غضون ذلك اكد جيك
سالفن استشار الامن القومي الامريكيه
تتابع الازمه وهي تتشاور مع البلدين
بشانها
سريعا تتصاعد الازمه الدبلوماسيه بين كندا
والهند منذره بالمزيد احدث خطوات التصعيد
جاءت من يودلهي معلنه تعليق خدمه
التاشيرات للكنديين
انتم على علم بالتهديدات الامنيه التي
تواجه مفوضيه
وقنصلياتنا في كندا وقد ادى ذلك الى تعطيل
عملها الطبيعي وبناء على ذلك فان قنصليتنا
غير قادره مؤقته على معالجه طلبات
التاشيره قبل ذلك بساعات اعلنت السفاره
الكنديه في نيودلهي تخفيض عدد دبلوماسيه
في البلاد بعد تلقيهم تهديدات عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي وفق بيان السفاره
في نيويورك جدد رئيس الوزراء الكندي جاستن
ترود واتهاماته للهند بقتل زعيم السيخ
هارديب سينغ نيجار لكنه ابقى على منافذه
للتفاهم معها
لا شك ان الهند دوله ناميه مهمه نحتاج
للعمل معها ليس فقط في الاقليم بل على
المستوى الدولي ولا نسعى الى استفزازها
والتسبب في مشاكل معها لكننا نتمسك بشكل
لا لبس فيه باهميه حكم القانون وحمايه
الكنديين ودعم قيمنا لذلك ندعو الحكومه
الهنديه للعمل سويا لتاسيس اليات تكشف لنا
حقيقه ما حدث لنتمكن من تحقيق العداله
والازمه التي تهدد عضوي الكومنويلث بقطيعه
دبلوماسيه محتمله تشغل ايضا الولايات
المتحده حليف البلدين في ملفات وقضايا
اساسيه
الخاصه ولكننا على اتصال دائم مع نظ
الكنديين نحن نتشاور معهم عن كثب وندعم
الجهود التي يبذلونها في هذا التحقيق وقد
كنت ايضا على اتصال مع الحكومه الهنديه
تفجرت الازمه يوم الثلاثاء الماضي عندما
اشارت رودو الى احتمال ان يكون عملائه
للمخابرات الهنديه وراى مقتل الزعيم
السيخي في حزيران الماضي غربيه كندا لكن
نيودلهي سارعت الى نفي تهمه اغتيال نيجار
الذي تتهمه بالنشاط الانفصالي وبالدعوه
الى انشاء دوله مستقله للطائفه السيخيه
ومعنى
استاذه العلوم السياسيه في جامعه نورت
ايسترن والمختص في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا
وسهلا بك دكتور ابرامز كيف تتابع هذه
القضيه بين الهند
وكندا هل تراها يعني فعلا ستؤدي الى ازمه
بعيده الامد امنيه مجرد
مرحله وقتيه ويمكن حلها بسهوله
بالتاكيد نعمل بان تحلل الامور بسرعه لكن
هذا ليس هو الاتجاه الذي تسير فيه الامور
على ما يبدو الامور سائره الى تصعيد حكومه
رودو مستمره في موقف على ان حكومه الهند
هي التي تقف وراء هذا الهجوم والحكومه
الهنديه من جانبها تقول هي تغطي على
المتطرفين السيخ ولا تاخذ بعين الاعتبار
الامن القومي الهندي وكلا البلدان
يتبادلان
الخطوات مثل الغاء
سمات الدخول طرد دبلوماسينا الى ذلك اتمنى
لو اكون اكثر تفاعلا لكن لا ارى ان هناك
تخفيفا في الازمه حاليا
الهنود في كندا كبيره جدا كيف سينعكس هذا
الوضع عليهم ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه في
المرحله القادمه
الحكومه الهنديه بالتاكيد تعتبروا ان كندا
بشكل عام كبلد ليس امنا ليس فقط لان وجود
عدد كبير من الهنود هناك عدد كبير من
السيخ ايضا وهم المعنيون مباشره لان
الحكومه الحركه الكلستانيه هي تتخذ موقفا
متطرفا وفي ولها انصار في المجتمع السيخي
داخل الهند
وخارج الهند هناك عدد كبير من الشتات من
السيخ يعيشون في الخارج واكبر عدد من
الجاليات السيخيه في الخارج تعيش في كندا
وهذا هو احد الاسباب الذي
جعل الهند تنظر بعين الريبه الى كندا ومن
دون حتى اي سبب
اضافه لقضيه هذه الكلستانيه في الشتات لا
تتعلق بكندا فقط بل قد تتعلق ببلدان اخرى
فيها اعداد كبيره من نسير خاصه الولايات
المتحده المملكه المتحده استراليا
وايطاليا ويجب ان نشير وانا اريد ان اؤكد
على هذه النقطه ان الغالبيه العظمى من
السر ليس من انصار هذه الحركه المتطرفه
ربما يودون زوالها لان تجعل من حياتهم
صعبه يعني هل الموضوع كلهم مرتبط بهذه
الشخصيه التي قتلت في كندا ام الموضوع
ابعد وله جذور اعمق برايك
لها ابعاد اكبر بكثير في الحقيقه هذه ليست
تتعلق بشخص واحد
وهي ما تسبب بحركه النمور الطالق الثانيين
طبعا هناك
لو كانت الحاله هي فعلا اغتيال مقصود كما
هو متصور عن هذه الحال هذا لا يتطلب
شخصا مفردا بحد ذاته الفرد بحد ذاته قد لا
يكون مهما لكن حاله العداوه بين الحكومتين
الهنديه
خاصه في عائله ترودو تعود الى عقود من
الزمن وهي مبنيه على السؤال الاخير اذا
سمحت لي يتعلق بدور الولايات المتحده هنا
خصوصا انا حريصا على القول انه يتم
التشاور مع الطرفين بشان هذه الازمه ما هو
هذا الدور
اعتقد ان كندا ستشعر بخيبه امل من رده فعل
المتحده لان كندا حليف مقرب وجار للوقت
المتحده ربما توقعت كانذا من بايدن ان
يخرج الى العلم ويقول نحن نصدق بكل ما
يقوله بدون اي تحفظ لكن على ماذا العام
الماضي كانت
الولايات المتحده تحاول التقرب من الهند
من حيث عدد سكانها واقتصادها وموقعها
لتكون مركز ثقل
ومضاد للصين
طبعا الوقت المتحده لا تريد ان تبعد اي من
البلدين لكن بموقفها هذا قد يفسر بانه
لصالح الهند ايضا
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه نورس في
العلاقات الدوليه
وصلنا الى ختام الحصد في
ملح
[موسيقى]